bonjour à vous à une fleur lespiau vous
êtes notre correspondante aux maliennes
fleurs 24 heures après l annonce du
départ des forces barkan est à kouba du
pays la junte au pouvoir a sommé cet
après midi à paris de retirer ses
soldats sans délai qu'est ce qu'il faut
comprendre
alors cette annonce est l'acte le
divorce entre eux mais entre le mali et
la france mais pour les maliens cette
demande de départ sans délai des forces
barca n'est pas cuba n'est pas une
surprise une annonce même salué à bamako
par une large partie de la population
malienne qui soutient mordicus les
autorités de transition demain par
exemple le mouvement populaire et anti
france français irait aux lots sur les
remparts a invité le peuple malien à se
rassembler place de l'indépendance pour
célébrer et bien le départ de la france
pour un mali s'ouvre à accompagner cette
fois-ci par de nouveaux partenaires
comme la russie par exemple un point de
vue nous ne fait tout de même pas
l'unanimité ici au sein de la société
civile ou encore la classe politique
d'opposition
pour eux il s'agit je cite d'une
surenchère inutile de la part des
autorités de transition qui n'ont pas de
vision sur le long terme et qui continue
de participer à l' isolement du mali un
mali qui rappelons le traverse une crise
sécuritaire mais également économiques
et politiques il salue cependant la
montée en puissance des forces armées
maliennes qui affirme avoir permis le
retour de la sécurité dans certaines
localités du centre du pays qui est ici
à l'épicentre du conflit mais cette
réponse militaire ne te feras pas
suffisante ils attendent de l'état qu'il
rétablisse l'ordre constitutionnel a en
mois de la fin de la période de la
transition
il demande également aux autorités des
mesures concrètes pour permettre avant
tout le retour des services de l'état
sur un territoire dont le contrôle lui
échappe aujourd'hui au deuxième merci
beaucoup à tous leurs fleurs l'esprit en
direct depuis bamako vous le disiez à
l'instance et propos sont considérés
comme une surenchère par une partie de
la population malienne le président
français a évidemment réagi depuis
bruxelles à 7
jonction la décision de réarticuler
dispositif militaire s'appliquera en bon
ordre at il dit on va écouter sa réponse
la réponse faite au chef de la junte
malienne
cette décision qui est le fruit d'une
évolution de la situation politique et
des choix souverain de la junte en
responsabilité au mali s'appliquera donc
elle s'appliquera simplement en bon
ordre pour que nous continuions
d'assurer pendant cette période la
sécurité de la mine usma et la sécurité
de toutes nos forces armées déployées
aujourd'hui au mali avec sécurité avec
laquelle je ne transigerai pas une seule
seconde